microphone should be plugged in so I
have to find a way to message him okay
I'm gonna go to the stream
okay I'm life if anyone's watching let
me know if things look okay I've moved
locations I was severely uh what's the
right word my foot was severely asleep
and now it's better because I'm not like
sitting on it I'm in my friend's place
and my friend is a YouTube celebrity he
might join he's also like mm rated and
chess so but we're gonna play the match
against Andris I don't know what the
match is gonna be what time is it where
he is he's in Sydney I think what time
is it in Sydney it's noon okay so it's 7
p.m. in California that's decent time
for both of us
I'm ready to play I guess I can go and
watch the volume low what time control
are you allowed to watch another
streamer on your own stream pretty sure
that's allowed yeah multi twitch if you
guys don't know what multi twitch is
click the link that Nathan f31 for
shared it's a great thing we're doing 5
minutes okay all I heard was 5 minutes
let's see
am i following him I'm following him I'm
gonna go to me chest org we're gonna
follow on us andris is a great person
and like commentator and coach and he
has a YouTube channel and his YouTube
videos are really really instructive
he's one of the few people who I
recommend that my students watch because
he's very good at explaining things
Nathan enough has money on me okay we're
gonna challenge to a game oh wait do I
have a pending challenge first of all I
do okay
it's good thing I checked that and let's
play can i zoom in a bit is that too
weird I don't think it's too weird
can you zoom out a little bit yeah good
luck oh I did not mean to play you six I
meant to play e5 well we're gonna play a
French that's not a good sign I just
mouse slipped on move one uh okay game
is starting and he's thinking why is he
thinking I moved to I wonder what type
of streamer he is because some streamer
is they take so much time to explain
their moves and they don't play quickly
enough and play d5 I also want to
introduce people to my friend his name
is cozy we've known each other since
since how long high school did sophomore
year of high school was 2010 eight years
what's up guys so this is cozy
he goes by clever programmer on YouTube
how many subscribers do you have one
hundred and seventy thousand plus now I
wait I think C 5 was a terrible move
because he could have played ninety five
but he was he was pre moving now I might
be bad nice do I give him the tape back
no do not give him a tape back here but
he was lagging ok ok yeah this is like a
moral conflict in chess that's on wait
I'm gonna take it again he gave me a
take back part eat ok there we go oh
yeah so wait have you got you've
streamed on YouTube this is a chest so
you can you should just read the
comments and tell me if there's anything
notable and I'll focus on the chest ok
so lovely of doing it I'll moderate the
chat yeah and then there's like
notifications like something pops up
here people sometimes I've donate to
subscribe or whatever ok that's awesome
guys this is super exciting like I'm
getting to actually see it from Eric's
perspective and hear his thoughts I
actually try to get coaching from him
give you like one lesson yes
back in the day actually don't know
theory in this position I want to play
g65 I look like b5 no f5 is actually
annoying threat because d5 is week
I like g6 yeah g6 you just like you
prevent the king so I play and then you
play on the Queen side b5 or when are
you thinking of canceling never actually
maybe at some point but the King is like
it's safe in the center I think here I
just want to pawn storm like just before
I'm just gonna push pawns yeah it was
about to sound like you know your nights
hanging yeah I mean okay so there's a
rule on me Chester not allowed to like
get help like you're not allowed to team
up against people I think you're the
level where you won't be able to tell me
- I don't think I can help you too much
here man like for people who don't
understand like the difference between
2000 and 2400 is like ridiculous if I
played like 20 games against Eric or
hundred games I would probably just lose
all of them so there's like a crazy
amount of difference but you would be
surprised how many terrible wonders I
make on streams I'm just not focused I
know I've made a lot of blunders - on on
stream I have a stream chest ball oh you
know this videos I allow that 5 that was
unnecessary I should've played h5
I should play the h5 after 80 devotion
looks weird I mean can you just leave
that there and then just try to either
Brooks you tarrif maybe just a for like
a 20 so here my King's French like the
French the king wants to stay in the
center so the center is like the most
closed place on the board music you guys
want like the chest broad type of music
you could ask Alexa we just has like
deep this but we don't want this video
to get taken off of youtube but it's
true that has happened to me as well but
this is twitch this isn't youtube but
twitch still like does copyright stuff
what would happen if we say Alexa
played chess brought music oh it's plain
like Chess Records might be if I was a
really good molex that stop good call I
forgot 95 to 96 is just for whole 97
even though it looks ugly it's actually
a decent idea I'm looking at tactics I'm
looking at Knight to e5 take me 5 to 3
883 it doesn't lead to anything though
well so I have Quincy five and twenty
five ranks are anything made threatening
stuff Oh if if he takes oh but he would
take all three take these out in check
that's unpleasant I should probably take
him seriously like he's a good player
I'm a good player two three wait be
three looks fun be three there's
discoveries in the end so what happens
if he checks you have to be three check
ninety-six king of AIDS I take C I take
C it'd be take a - what you can't stop
me from cleaning Oh what you only live
once that's pretty disgusting in a good
way I play them oh I have a - four
against him I think always later it is
like one minute mm-hmm I have no idea
what's going on here makes you tick okay
if he takes with the C pawn there's
x-ray vision yes sir there's some
there's at the very least I take on thee
Knight takes c3 Knight before or
something yeah that's nice or he's
probably debating like ninety six or
eight take b3 jeez if he does 8hb three
wait now I just want to take on b3
doesn't leave time you think I take e5
I take on a three and wait if you tell
us fun then he takes back what are you
feeling and I take e five Chuck oh okay
looks really fun
a tactical massacre and then he doesn't
have the g6 square she is if you see I
mean what is he thinking about he has to
take he can't lose his Queen yeah I take
here I must have something better 94 94
doesn't move actually night deep-linking
be warned it's similar let's remove this
pawn and then I take the tagging is
Queen the Knights sort of attacked
I didn't calculate this far though you
could could you do Queen before offer a
queen trade and attack is night twice
he's running 9600 weight clean up for is
a really good move I want to repeat it
like calculated this time I played five
if I can take a freaky or queen of four
again goes back or I might sort of
trapped yeah wait this is really bad and
there's no increment either you should
not have to take back regrets okay I'm
gonna play Knight each for its only move
I see to not lose too much material he's
gonna play 96 he's gonna take the rook
might play f6 and Queen h6 no King g8
it's gonna be ugly
oh that's crushing actually that's
devastating Nagi to know
I should just ask for like 10 take backs
oh he goes sorry
you played c5 first I didn't even see
that okay I read very much I'm realizing
this is casual so you can help me like
if you want to suggest okay cool doesn't
get here
well that was good andris message wait I
want to take back I justify c4 it but
it's too late I'm sure we'll play
multiple games it was kind of sure
things are there budget and believe in
that HS watching yeah I mean we both
have decently high ratings there's some
times like when there's when it's like
the top game on the site yeah over 100
viewers I would ask you a lot more
questions of the time controls were a
little bit longer and you can ask me
questions sometimes the chat asks
questions too and you mean just this is
actually a really fun line because
there's this x-ray vision against the
bishop yeah and if I have to be really
careful here so like for example is it
like Bishop d6 runs into Bishop a6 just
it's like it's winning for white like
out of nowhere at the hell cuz tactics
it's good he's thinking here too is like
he could easily someone I've never seen
Bishop a6 this is a type of setup black
plays without knowing theory like just
neck normal squares for the pieces but I
know theory and I know stock wishes
recommendations so after okay so the
idea of a 36 [ __ ] of a 6 is what if
he'd face by Shep's 194 so they should
take a four-bit should take me 7
I'd like there's so many problems with
this night hanging with check and like
there's no response after today and what
about okay
hey 97 is a decent move but now this I'm
gonna buy pressure 95 maybe
Queen see it's interesting sometime c5
is father c4 as possible 3 for you you
thought looks pretty interesting okay II
four little if you say it's interesting
we'll play it it might not be good I
like because I want to like maybe even
castle and like try to attack him mmm
yeah actually if we can open the file if
we can castle
right open the file gether up to you 140
classes it's a lot to ask for
right and I feel like maybe d5 could be
a weak pawn for him to at some point
that's possible yeah if we trade we get
some iqp yep there's a very similar
variation from the black side called the
Cambridge Springs where it's playable
for black but when you're playing it as
white and you have extra tempo I forgot
about this so you could take the knight
and double the pawns but I think that's
a double pawns leads to open files it
should be for coming out oh you should
be forking up on maybe have some time
advantage it's always a nice thing in
blitz if you know you're opening you
just get an early time advantage yeah
Knight b6 that night is going to defund
trying to evaluate this ending at 19,000
knowing it's really annoying
oh you're trying to think about just
taking just taking and we get some
structure let's do it he says five games
yeah um first two fine
I don't know he was tired of London is
tired of life this was a battle in
history you can't get tired of London is
this reversed Cambridge Springs this is
reverse Cambridge Springs yes Oh X 159
yeah he has to go he has a daughter
ouch well there's a there's a viewer who
said you would give me 10,000 bits if I
won the match but I don't know what that
includes a forfeit win well your queen
is that's fine no you wait my Queens
hang thank you for telling me I just saw
like a positional weakness yeah rook see
one's gonna come next
what's up for people who are in the
twitch chat what is your what are you
guys as ratings
what's your chest level I'm curious
because I want to ask questions that
would be more suitable for you guys it's
actually a good question
he's attacking deform but not really
good looks
Bishop h6 is a funny mood yeah I was
looking at that f6 square
I'd just imagine him just like ignoring
his crying daughter to finish this game
I'm tempted to just play rook g1 there's
so many options here like there's a t5
rook g1 castling queenside
rook c1 a4 I just a matter of choosing
the move yeah I like your move there
should be there should be five if he
plays f6 I'm thinking I would just take
on f6 if he takes back Knight takes f6
as a fourth it's true no now he actually
wants to play f6 oh but but now he also
can't take a three it's so slow looking
move but it just restricts his pieces
and then retreat be civilized
rook c1
my time advantage from earlier just
disappeared and I've had these
structures before it it's an unusual
structure but yeah white spawns every
week but so like these phones are also
weak at some point I feel like do you
wanna play Knight c5 yeah I don't wanna
wait in you don't I don't want to allow
the trader tonight for Bishop okay why
is that because if I turn off my Knights
then his Knights just so solid I can
never remove it uh-huh I want to allow
possibility of maybe playing Knight c3
to trade off his mics okay
h5 is a decent move because he wants to
play h4 mm-hmm so I'm gonna play each
for myself to him shoutout to ginger 64
another streamer it's a great thing
about twitch like there's so many other
chess streamers and like usually we
watch each other like support each other
oh wow that's actually cool what's up
ginger what's his rating actually don't
know I've watched his streams but I
forget his rating is either expert 1000
pretty sure you around expert level
forgive me if I'm wrong though maybe not
maybe I can play with you at some point
I have to like go back and watch his
stream didn't even open it like see if
like he just has a baby daughter in his
lap you just hung up by t6o I don't even
know if I want to take the rook my
knight looks so strong but I rook is a
yeah I wonder if you felt bad for it so
badly the riskiness or f5 or is that not
because nine out of five I'm just going
to double up it's tough when you have a
weak pawn on a half-open file
yeah I can't advance yes that e4 pawn
came in handy
I wanted a rock on the e-file
yeah he's he's gonna die wait he wants
to take on d4 when he defends upon but
c6 falls tactics should be okay he can
fork me but I have rook c7 check or in
this case my queen takes these Hicks
doesn't that's Gary Brown that's a good
move that's a really good move we need
I'm looking at rook c7 and wait my
bishop sort of hanging though be quiet I
might want to like clear up g1 oh wow
okay I know I can attack him from like
so many different directions yeah okay
he's being desperate well he just
ordered a pawn oh yeah now he's running
at three I mean we could just trade yeah
let's just trade it's a boring approach
wait a minute okay King he was running
Queen at 4 don't fly yeah 10 seconds is
nice time lead no he he worked me you
didn't tell me about that mu oh okay
this is where the flagging technique
comes into play
he might be lagging to wait he didn't
take a free rook I'm confused
he's probably just like terribly
distracted this very low-quality game
well I can see Queen g13 pawn this is
such a low-quality game uh what am i
doing wait I'm meeting and this is mate
next move
oh oh oh nice unexpected checkmate there
you go
he goes you had a free rook what oh my
god everybody is going crazy
hanging growth question why that was
was just bad Jess um wait he wants a
rematch Oh
Oh I thought he had to go now ice no no
no yeah he said after that that's why he
only wants to play up to five gotcha
okay well I play this line against him
so I was showing this line earlier in
the stream I'm hoping he takes here so
then we take here there's a funny trap
to this yeah yeah this is it so like it
looks like the inner chest but let's see
if he knows what to do
the trap is if he plays Bishop at four
yeah g3 i-5
oh he's falling into us yeah I fell into
this was like 23 oh my god so great I
show this like all the viewers know this
one yeah okay so I had this in a
tournament game like five six years ago
I was white so I was playing in 1800 I
didn't know it and I walked into it and
then I I managed to witness is white I
played like Queen e2 and then Queen h5
there was some counter play like okay
blacks winning a piece is this another
Lal moment yes it is tell them it's a
how do you become I am without knowing
this trap
it's so rare like it's not fake but you
don't find this every day he's like he
does cover looks like that there's a
good number of traps and chests which
are just like not known but they they
still happen often it's just okay we
have to play King to you or Queen f7 I
have some big memory of -7 Iman yeah so
White's getting pawns for the piece
that's something I have to live with
okay I'm just trying to remember I'm
mostly
I'm gonna play Queen f7 at some point I
want a Castle queenside and then use the
extra minor piece to attack maybe Bishop
e7 Bishop e6 ambitions try and treat
this position nicely there's a piece
that won't look good then Bishop e6 yeah
it would follow your of a PD Castle
queenside castle I mean you don't really
have weaknesses I mean he does have
three pawns for the piece so it's not
like a completely decisive advantage but
the extra piece is so valuable when
there's attacking possibilities I'm
tempted to I'm tempted to Castle
probably not a great move though this
Bishop takes c6 2007 what else to do
push shove d5 Knight c3
I might have to do some deep
calculations here Castle queenside
Bishop takes c6 166 2007 and you may
need to attack his King
now I'm looking Bishop d5 I'm attacking
Joshua I was looking at the outs do that
it looks very simple and he can't play
c4 easily he can't play 93 but still
it's not like a threat and you always
have efficient you two are their meds
okay I mean let me Mach storm can't you
just do queen x e6 what is going on why
can i mod him I'm so confused
wait this is so weird oh I'm in his chat
wait he resigned why did he resign aha
nice that was a mouse whip but I had
just too many of those because I was
like yeah I quit because I was like you
can just do quintic I'm so confused I'm
in the mod ginger wait I'm so confused
why can't I click those three click that
click that no I don't want to report him
to almost made him report you ginger if
you like when I stream I go from 2000 to
like 15 oh I'm in the wrong chat I mean
I was in his chat I'm not in my chest oh
no wonder when I'm asking questions like
I'm like that's weird
oh my gosh oh and people cheered more
and I was ignoring everyone oh because I
read it in I didn't want to do that or
that's where's a game there hey guys
nathan is like Rafi notice me how are
you doing how are you guys doing it's so
nice to see you guys think
for cheering over the last the last like
the whole stream we've we've been
interacting with the wrong chap yeah
we've been yeah I was like man I'm
asking questioning these guys are rude
okay let me ask you guys again cuz I
didn't get an answer to this what is
your guys is rating
what is your guys's level chest because
um so then I can ask him questions that
are more in line with your rating say
something strange to Eric and confuse
them quickly f5 but that's not like
confusing five illegal I mean everything
that said sometimes confuses in 1750
Nathan nice mm you got some strong
people watching your stream like yeah
like it's it's a strong girl you got no
wallet II people watching you I'm trying
to play the opening that used to play
like this Grand Prix setteth oh I love I
didn't play with 92 I don't think I
would play a four yeah I wouldn't Castle
I do it a bit different you would crush
me mute him close time okay so these are
all the notifications that we received
so Neath like what are the bits so bits
one bit is one penny so what so ice so
so 100 bits he is like a buck yes down
so I think the most bits that anyone
donated making it rain yeah no nathan is
like on a bit street or a bit storm that
even a thing bit connect maybe we're
gonna clap for and then treat we might
trade Queens
very possibly trade Queens
um well I was trying to mod wait am I in
the wrong chat again no now you're in
the right yeah you're so wrong you're in
the wrong choice I have it open this is
the right one look it even has this
stuff in room at the top yeah my my
highest like a bit donation was thirty
thousand bits okay I shout out to koi TV
he's probably sleeping right now
overseas can I just take a pawn for free
or maybe if I person then I take a pond
um I mean I would just take that pawn
like you use thinking you could win e4
yeah but this isn't intermezzo now guys
are strong oh shout out to Braden
another fan and viewer and students you
will if you make sure your position all
right take the pond we're gonna take
here and there's also I take the do I be
greedy in this position he has yeah you
can be sugar I felt like in earlier
situation when he does it you know when
you have in Castle then this type of
stuff you can't do that I think c4 is
really powerful here really because it
makes him neither an outpost it shuts
down and you discover checks it makes my
bishop depressed but okay that looks
like this line I think he's almost
confusing with another line like that's
usually uh my bishop is really depressed
right now can you play Knight a three
here I feel like and know the bishop
bishop the bishop Sutekh own ad agency
or or night ec3 but I'm wait I have an
idea
can we trick him to taking the bishop
and just treat it like bishop never mind
I was thinking Bishop g2 Knight take a
to Queen B 3 B is rook take a - okay how
about Knight be easy three
wait wait wait wait wait deep
calculation there's a detour take a two
this should take before rook ticket one
queen take a one C take before Queen
eight ah it's too hopeful my first
impression was just Queen b3 did you
just say that or no no I don't like me
me three it develops I just want to
continue developing I like that move
okay like I would have played I would
have moved my knight back but now
looking at this it looks like white
still has a lot of pressure with the
knight on b5 then like I'm showing it I
might want to play there should be 283
like this he's like this reminds me of a
French gone wrong this is like this is a
grant like a Grand Prix I wouldn't gone
wrong kind of wait what's the current
score oh I I've won two games I feel
like I don't deserve to be ahead here my
quality of play hasn't been great but
like resign people asking about Chicago
open yeah anyone that's in the chat he's
playing with Chicago open let me know I
know Nathan is may be infinite flash
dresses he's taking so much time okay
Bishop e7 Bishop d2 so that so what
you're just trying to take that night or
what yes okay when do you take it he'll
check a waitress back I mean there might
not be any reason to take right away
how about 90 see three years you still
don't like that for summers all has you
drop the pawn okay
Oh choices choices maybe it's just king
h1 yeah I like that I learned from one
of the grandmasters who's the one on yes
sir
no what was that website ICC - sure who
used to teach on there there's German
Linsky and there was like another guy
Alterman the gambit guy thinks you're
mullinski said or Larry Larry Larry
Christensen Christensen yeah I learned
from him he said like whenever you play
it for you want to play King each one
you're gonna hand at hand that's
actually true okay and then put the
bishop anymore yeah I like I had to play
an idea three like okay he wants to meet
me oh maybe Rick F 3 looks decent it
looks weird but yeah item I'm thinking
the bishop will one day attack that rook
and I'll be annoying is such a weird
position but I like it weird it's making
him think I know James well
can bring the night back to b5 join our
odd position well I forgot without the
pawn now rook wait a minute I have to be
careful g3 didn't take on d4 yes well
this is such a weird position my bishop
is again depressed yeah I know Queen can
go to e7 at some point and that looks
good almost
but he's not turning anything okay and
your knight can come to c7 I don't know
what it would do there but it looks good
play the smooth let me just push the
pawn like why not mmm
wait what's material I'm up a pawn okay
I'm still up upon so we could trade I
could play h5 maybe yeah and then maybe
when the e5 pawn someday you can play
Bishop a2 and threaten beating be cheap
should a to is a decent man 25 or
something but G choose attack let's do
this it's defense Oh take and king wait
this is scary let's play c5 smooth here
and then here before or at some point
before yeah I just have to make sure he
doesn't meet me I don't have time yeah
Oh what
[Music]
that's so sad that was kind of
disgusting Wow what just happened there
dude that's like the made against Josh
Dugan
yes this up to show that YouTube clip is
some way okay that's okay
well it's tied two to two but that's
annoying I could have had like a 3-1
lead so close sometimes when I lose a
game I just get tilted like it's
difficult emotionally yeah okay let's
play let's play a semi slow we might
have another Cambridge Springs mouse I
feel like it'll be so much faster ride
masses and it doesn't work for me that's
I just lose track bad that's so odd only
issue is when I get sweaty like that
it's so annoying and then I start
shaking like when I play the car oh I
was like I was just sweating my hands
okay we're going down son
one of you like these typical lines um
how do I peel my bananas that's a very
good question Nathan I usually do it
from the stem either question for the
chat does anyone recognize Kazi from
YouTube because he was a pretty big
following like anyone who watches videos
about coding maybe I seen you before if
any yeah it depends if you guys do
coding then there's a high chance to
seen before I don't know what kind of
jobs do people with chest to I mean I
feel like a lot of them are probably
coders he goes a Python programmer hyde
st mountain nice i oj let me get my here
check it out clever programmer shirt i'm
reppin that
wait what from stay no way you remember
me from state infinite that's
interesting
wait Bishop take b5 does not work it
doesn't wait Han take take take I can
take on f3 so it took me five night take
me five Bishop do you got three Queen
day got three Bishop h2 check and I can
attack his Knights Bishop I think he
miscalculated
ooh it's ringing to Prince I can still
play this oh he maybe will play out for
wait this is so weird we keep getting
until all these like weird positions but
I can play I can play Queen b8 here at
four I'm up a piece currently for two
phones infinite flash shows what's your
real name in have I played against you
25 wait Queenie five now if F for I can
take whoa Nathan has played me over the
board really and apparently he beat me
god dammit
you know who you beat who is now like
playing US Championships what's his name
the kid I wonder I wonder yeah I know I
wonder drew Fabiano you be the wonder
yeah he drew Fabiano first round he
played a good game like he was finding
all these moves that probably I don't
like was not finding she I guess he's
just about 2600 fidei the fact that you
like him and made him cry I beat him
under made him cry then played a dream
his brother
yeah he tried that same day so yeah but
but he beat me before that and he
made me crime late this kid is so he was
so tiny and he had to stand up on his
seat to actually reach the chess board
and play the move and he was playing and
then he just like crushed me the first
game we played the second game I ended
up winning oh he said no I lost
Renaissance tonight Nathan Ferguson are
youare you Asian Nathan I actually met
Nathan uh two weeks ago using San
Francisco wait Nathan do you live in San
Francisco or you were just visiting
don't want to ask personal questions but
I'm just curious okay let me focus on
this game is amazing follow you guys
yeah boy okay okay I think I can tell
you dude wow that's a surprise but
that's amazing holy crap it's like it's
a small world yeah that's awesome man
that's actually really cool yeah I
wonder is insane
I'm just mesmerized by this position
he's still threatening at for those
queens defended and I don't know what to
do
I could play Bishop at four and then he
takes me his triple pawns but he's still
up upon or up to pawns can you but it
seems like okay is king so exposed it
has to be something here in 95 maybe can
you just move your queen back and then
bring your Bishop back and save it and
just be up a piece you're up know like
queen bee at four still is you can take
that pawn with your Bishop and double
his pawns yeah I mean I'm looking I'm
looking for something or I don't know if
there's anything more he's up on claim I
won the piece so
I don't know this too much time but I'm
very curious here seems like interesting
possibly oh wait what woody 593 wait
what but I thought after f4 you can do
bishop takes that foreign if he takes
trade Queens he takes back and rook
takes d1 oh that's much simpler actually
yeah you saw the simple line I saw the
complicated line I was thinking might be
three earlier yeah I was thinking this
and then Knight b3 and okay or taken
then Knight B 3 and then Queen d5 I
don't know no this is so simple though
cuz it's like these pins again with the
x-ray vision there's a bit we're going
on okay we both forgot about knight c6
okay but we can wait oh wait i'm okay
they're telling me not to flag let's
play queen g5 this is not what I wanted
but let's get some initiative this is
difficult
I'm down two pawns now and I'm flagging
maybe wait this is really bad I'm gonna
play h6 and then idea is to someday play
rock a horror cage for massive rook
lifts which will probably never happen
now the plan is to do this system this I
spent way too long that one moment 97
could be an aunt I mean I don't really
think it does anything here but look at
this like they're trying to out bits
each other uh-huh outbid each other okay
oh he wants to play Ritchie one but okay
let's not get for it
Schneider 6:9 h4 will look good at some
point but probably Oh Queen takes up six
Queen takes f6 Knight of five no way
this isn't really good this is really
bad hold on I have to go for it though I
mean with Jesus like this could be
really bad mate rogue g7 yeah yeah
here's a nice mate Regina Queen e2
mm-hmm well I need a flag for all of you
telling me not to flag yeah
no that was the end of the the match I
forgot we were playing bass out of five
and not first to five oh that was a
really key game you want me to jump on
live stream so I can lose against Urich
you could if you want wait on your live
stream yeah my life is good you'll get a
lot more viewers I think do I lose a
Twitter poll - I lost a Twitter poll
wait there's 13 minutes left I think
they're 13 minutes left you got up
Nathan F a thousand bits wait ha how's
your Twitter hole doing um I don't know
Twitter's slow guys how many votes yeah
I have 33% I have over a hundred votes
okay whoever's watching this live stream
guys right now go to that link and vote
for Eric okay send him the link go set
up he's putting on amazing show guys so
just go and make sure you vote for him
because we need him to win how many
percent how many votes there's only 12
minutes left okay do the math how many
votes does he have hammer hammer has
about half the votes so he has about 170
and you have hundred and I have about
110 I need 60 more votes Oh too much to
ask
60 more votes I think I think I'm gonna
do it but don't give up you guys are
watching this jump on just do it now
it's just a Twitter poll just go and
vote do it do it do it and if you do it
then come back in just comment
let's see comment banana okay once you
vote say it banana
elastic hold is saying make fifty
nutritive counts uh whatever it takes is
twelve minutes like we can really make
it happen guys
I suggest let's freakin do it everyone's
saying banana whoa okay we got Nathan
voted we got dusty Mountain just voted
oh my gosh we got stuck in a flash of
another thousand bits oh man I don't
know if I care about the twenty five
dollars anymore
well I care about beating hammer because
I can't listen that's the most important
thing do this nice messy Marvin yes DJ
Breck beautiful in the meantime I'll
just play fans okay cool um wait to
anything change okay here I'll play you
I'll play your next game okay I'll
challenge you from my phone okay no
let's do it let's do hand in brain is
this casual oh this is rated or we can
do blindfold chess okay yes yes yes yes
let's do that
after no we can do it now oh okay cool
do this so okay I'm gonna sit backwards
wait what's the potion okay we got to
make sure that they can see you clearly
okay okay cool okay
Oh see three okay see three cool he says
I'm the dude you met at the airport in I
delighted to Nawaz brother oh yeah I
remember him
he also has a YouTube channel right he
just played hey ideas D for guys I
finally 25 okay wait wait wait wait what
what Khan did you take up on g5 sorry I
heard the capture sound I just assumed
one dig deeper sound here so d5
the head of Eric's the back of Eric's
head is very sexy thank you
Thank You dusty Mountain sorry not sorry
okay let's see he just played Bishop c5
oh no you know this theory this is a
really annoying line
what's his rating 1725 hey he's
beautiful
uh D takes c6 do you take thee thick yes
okay this is just annoying to play in
vine fold because like pieces get
scattered I should take that to be me
too what did you take me but me take
these things she knows what he's doing
umm wait no this should be six in the
computer know why is this wrong I'll
play Knight bTW - wait whoa no no no did
you play it
no wait Knight bTW - Bishop a6 could
it's almost me but then c4 how are you
seeing this area okay Knight bTW - like
busy basics is almost mate wait a minute
try up I have my phone on c3 still right
yeah I do
okay so there's basic c4 how much time
do I have
when I get below 20 seconds I'll start
playing like I'll turn around and just
start playing okay you played that move
which basics c4 and I play against one
of your friends and then you can say
that name of the piece and I'm sure just
if you if we do that it has to be a
casual game it can't be rated okay
so stressed about this rated bit war
here you're at the top now but one bit
not anymore
Jesus should I just come in and drop
some this okay he played at five
i five unexpected when I take you for
King ticket to pot I got three okay now
it's a scary position because Rick I
fate happens and some lines Queen h4
happens and some lines g3 Queen H like
you know this is crazy
wait I'm a long time right oh I'll play
I'm gonna play this but g3 f-pawn will
be my shield Castle Bishop III crazy
position tell me when I'm below 20
seconds okay what how much time is one
minute five seconds d5 quantity huh
remove like reticulation
Montague d520 second Queen to b3 you
want to play yes wait 20 seconds I was
still seeing the position decently
that's crazy there's no time to think
these pawns are really scary but at
least before it's under control
3:24 happens it's actually tricky
because I'm rotating everything
worst case scenario I set my bishop
person points and he's about to flag I'm
in some danger too but I'll play quickly
wait my microphone is over here yeah
t3 lag time flag wow that blockade is
strong for free Brooke that is a strong
blockade my friends you're not gonna
flag Eric that's not gonna happen okay
[Music]
that Bishop a6 is almost maybe not
almost mate but it's scary
I think the Twitter poll is probably
over oh I was coming back there's four
minutes left four minutes left behind
12% how many votes you need any 12% okay
guys wait what's what's your Twitter
following do you have that like much
influences a little super long super low
don't vote for minutes laughs wait did
you vote for me I don't think okay we'll
play one more person I don't go on
Twitter
we'll play Nathan F because he is is
he's a bit leader
oh he's not the bit leader we'll play
him anyway it was BG challenging me to
know okay uh we can do let's do hand in
brain so you just say a piece and I make
him a pawn Knight
I shouldn't be hover hon no you're
opening sir hahaha Knight Bishop pawn
pawn wait it's not what I want okay
I know you like to play the other ting I
gave it a youtube video that is uh not
the specific variation that's something
similar
Bishop g5 oh I'm sorry bishop I mean
it's not the move I wanted to play that
okay wait what did you want to play I'm
curious I'm not gonna say it cause it's
still like it's over this game yes sir
yeah we have to go over this because
this is an important line to know
actually while we're lagging Fred let me
know in the chat if we're lagging
because there should not be a new lag
yes I can check to twitch alright this
should be sick
no laughs okay that's good watch out for
time - yeah
queen did you see the coffin for
infinite West yes
oh no idea that's what this is a move
that we should have played earlier
inside a Bishop g5 okay I was thinking
about it but I didn't want agree
Nathan to hear all my ideas that's why
Mountain
Oh you've played anything before I've
been him
four times before I don't know why it
says three pawn like this doesn't make
any sense
we played four times before but it says
three oh I understand okay never mind
because this is the far right is a score
just for today just say the piece say
the piece so you know you're gonna move
their show okay
were you thinking about something else
oh oh sorry oh you're thinking about
taking on yeah I thought you were like
thinking about where to put the bishop
Knight pawn
Oh Nathan screaming - yeah yes no way to
multitwitch it doesn't pop up that you
streaming and used well no but we have
good pieces I want to give commentary
but I won't I like help you with news
yeah pawn pawn okay play slowly
Queen serious we go wait gosh okay when
we got below 15 seconds oh yeah this is
harder than it looks guys what does the
plan after this game after this game I
don't know the Twitter poll is over I
think is there gonna be a celebration
we'll check the Twitter poll after this
game and then determine whether to
celebrate or cry he is thinking giving
some queen
I wanted to get out of that pen there's
more of a discovered attack or sorry
like a discovered attack I wanna get out
of that go over the line oh yeah we're
gonna go over the line that this game
had because the move order is and horns
yeah yeah in the future I just have to
do like a opening string and I just go
over openings favorite pawn you're okay
just just name a piece just needing they
don't you don't have to like think of a
move just Hani whatever piece and I'll
try and I'll try and keep it going okay
Bishop Knight good job Lee packs thanks
for the follow pawn I think it's time to
take over okay he's up 10 seconds I have
eight seconds but tried my best to help
you name six
we have three seconds fool haha
[Music]
the trick was to play b4 at the right
time and then yeah like already I think
he's losing
ip65 yeah jeez oh good game Nathan okay
let's go and look at that opening quick
opening lesson Twitter poll I officially
lost unfortunately these are final
results but thank you thank you everyone
for voting I was close I should have
probably screamed earlier when the poll
was released but what to do good job
hammer
you almost got as close yeah I gained
like 15% during the stream I think
anyway this opening we're gonna go back
to this position so when you said pawn
you you were going for a f5 right yeah I
like to Castle first because a lot of
the times a black will play 97 Omaha and
you still you could play off 5 here but
you still delay o'clock wants to play d5
oops
laughter cast 187 d5 is the plan so you
play Queen e1 and then d5 is not
possible cuz take take and then the
Knights pinned and you just take 95 so a
lot of times Blackwell Castle and then
you play at 5 and it's strong in this
position because a lot of times black
will take like what he did in the game
and then Queen h4 right right right idea
being Bishop g5 is coming next
yeah this line like I learned from Boris
Alterman like he was showing to play
it's such a good
I look at the percentage for lighting
these games this is a masters this is a
really good pattern and I have myself
just done it so many times whereas like
if you can get your Bishop to h6 and
your Knight to g5 like so many times a
game is just like over so in this
position I would probably play Bishop g5
and keep that pin well it depends what
black toes right but there are a lot of
positions where I get the white Bishop
to h6 and I'll get my White Knight to g5
and it's just like game over because
then I'm just writing you know take his
Bishop on g7 and then go with the Queen
to 87 yeah because blacks night is on e7
like there's really no defensive
resource for the h7 pawn actually showed
this line and the st. Louis Chess Club
YouTube video so if you guys want to see
that line just search for Sicilian
Knight c3 and my name and you should
find it but yeah like a lot of times
people play a 95 or 94 and this is where
Bishop g5 is strong because you have so
much preference this Knight f6 is not
possible because of the pin right rocky
okay the line I showed you what's wrong
with Bishop h6 there go back a little
bit so in this position yeah I like
Bishop g5 is just more direct because
it's winning my force oh we're probably
Bishop h6 arrggh would be Knight take f3
I'm never after day and it's though oh
yeah because yeah yeah you're right Mike
wanted before as well as massively yeah
okay I like I like Bishop g5 here and
then just keep I think the game I showed
is something like this I don't know
blacks position just falls apart yeah a
great line so like in the game that we
had when you played at five I was really
hoping you would play Queen e1 then if
he castles then you play Queen h4 and
it's the same it's just okay so go
battle so what did I play there
you played Bishop g5 immediately which a
lot Bishop u6 oh wow so so the
difference when you say allow can you
show me with Queenie one light like an O
Bishop e6 here I think the difference is
that you
preserve the e6 we're potentially for
the night LG v square sorry the g5
square okay so like if let's say castle
Queen h4 Bishop e6 then it's just losing
tactically to take take my g5 and
there's a fork okay
I mean while let's say there should be
six here I mean the very least we could
take tick tick and the center is opening
up g6 is attacked twice take I mean I
assume something right Knight g5 like 96
or Queen e6 coming maybe even we can
admit this classic mates you're okay of
course we're take F 7 but wait oh it's
not it's not a classic mean I got an IG
8 okay well at least we would material
yeah
at 96 is also threatening to win
materials right yeah I think Bishop g5
is too committal like yeah it was
usually these lines you want to play the
move that you're gonna play no matter
what right that move was Queen e1 and
you want to stay flexible yeah okay
anyway I think I'm gonna end it there
I've applied to catch I have to check in
I will be back in the future this is sad
I'm leaving La yeah I'll be back in the
meantime you can check out cause ease
content on YouTube clever programmer he
has really good videos about how to code
and how to be awesome at life oh wow
kill me can we kill me is like my
biggest fan how and she always arrives
late to the stream haha like she always
says hi when I'm about to say bye to
everyone thank you downward is
heavenward for a hundred bits thank you
everyone for the bits especially bg7 KD
94 and never uh outperforming they
didn't fight one bit yeah
shoutout to San Diego I did I traveled
to like three California
cities over the last three weeks I did
not make it to San Diego but if I come
back to California I'll try to make it
to San Diego next time
super dank fire hasta luego duskie
Mountain thank you for the zero bits
yeah um I will see you guys in the
future
bye and have a good day or a good good
night or a good bishop or a good night